pantoise a le sens de la tradition cette
ville du val d'oise célèbre depuis vicié
que la foire saint martin cette année
c'est la 828e sixième édition cette fois
recettes une fête de rue inspiré du
moyen-âge avec comme toujours ses
célèbres parents et son incontournable
jungle est le petit vin des coteaux de
pontoise béatrice pignède et abdel jeudi
rebelles vers un petit verre voire
plusieurs loges anglais 4 à 5 tonnes de
l'art en griller les ingrédients de la
saint martin date du moyen-âge
il y avait un moine qui avait laissé
tomber ses harengs ici ils pouvaient
plus repartir les amendes dues aux
pauvres je me tiens et depuis j'ai à 826
bien poiret en banlieue il ya qu'ici
qu'on veut enlever le réveil dimanche
matin régulièrement devant la hongroise
à chacun sa technique rustique ou plus
sophistiqués
mais difficile de garder son élégance
qui vont vous respecter la tradition
tradition c'est de manger des harengs
grillés comme ça à mains nues alors
c'est peut-être un petit peu dégoûtant
de 6 après pourchet t couteau mais c'est
hyper sympa et c'est très bon il sait y
faire culinaire tu vois ce que
j'apprécie c'est sa croissance avec la
sainte vierge de pise en complément
comme au temps des moines la vente du
vin des coteaux de pontoise le jungle
est sert à financer les déshérités de la
communauté à déguster uniquement pendant
la saint martin un vin pétillant à c'est
un vin rigoler achats ne seront pas
suspendus bandeau la forêt de la saint
martin c'est jusqu'au bourg novembre à
pontoise au niveau là